they have made
before we come to plymouth's questions
[Music]
before i've become to prime minister
questions i would like to point out that
the british sign language interpretation
proceedings is available to watch on
parliament live tv we now start with
questions to the prime minister bitmap
alumi
number one mr speaker i'm ballista
uh mr speaker today i'm wearing a purple
tie in recognition of the international
day of people with disabilities this
coming friday
in july we published the uk's first
national disability strategy to help
create a society that works for
everybody
mr speaker i know that the thoughts of
the whole house will be with those
continuing to face disruption caused by
storm irwin my right-hand friend the
secretary of state for business energy
and industrial strategy will update the
house on the continuing response to
storm irwin after these questions mr
speaker this morning i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
and i have a shared commitment to
protecting our natural environment and
improving our biodiversity across the
country indeed it's why i'm campaigning
to extend the chilton's area of natural
beauty towards the south west of
hitching
would my right honourable friend set out
how he plans to strengthen the
protections for our countryside whilst
also ensuring that housing developments
are both green and sustainable for the
long term
yes indeed this is because i could tell
my honorable friend that natural england
is considering an extension of the
children's area of outstanding uh
natural beauty and i'm sure they will
listen to his passionate appeal very
carefully
we now come to the leader of the
opposition kia stammer
uh thank you mr speaker can i join the
prime minister and his words on
disability and the victims of extreme
weather can i also mark world aids day
extraordinary advances mean people
living with hiv on effective treatment
can now enjoy normal life expectancy and
are no longer at risk of passing on the
virus it's within our hands to end new
transmissions in the uk this decade we
must do so mr speaker
as millions of people were locked down
last year
was a christmas party thrown in downing
street for dozens of people on december
the 18th
prime minister
uh
mr speaker
what i can tell the right honourable
gentleman is that
is that all guidance was followed uh
completely during number ten and can i
and can i can i recommend uh to the
right honourable gentleman that he does
uh the same uh with his own christmas
party which is advertised for december
the 15th for which to which
unaccountably he's failed to invite the
the the deputy leader mr speaker
uh
nice try but that won't work mr speaker
the the defense seems to be the defense
seems to be no rules were broken well
i've got the rules that were in place at
the time prime minister of this party
they're very they're very clear mr
speaker
you
you must
you must not have a work christmas lunch
or party
does the prime minister really expect
the country to believe that while people
were banned from seeing their loved ones
at christmas last year it was fine for
him and his friends to throw a boozy
party in downing street
[Applause]
mr speaker i've said i've said what i've
said about uh number 10 and uh the
events of 12 months ago but he since he
asked about what we're asking the the
country to do this year mr speaker which
i think is uh frankly a more relevant uh
consideration
the important thing to do mr speaker is
not only to follow the guidance which we
have which we have set out but also when
it comes to dealing with the omicron
variant to make sure that as we've said
that you wear a mask in
on public transport and in uh in in
shops mr speaker and that you self i
state if you come into contact uh with
somebody uh with somebody who has uh
omicron mr speaker and above all what
we're doing is strengthening our
measures at the borders uh but
particularly and i think this would be
very valuable for everybody to hear uh
get your booster mr speaker
i know that i know the right honourable
gentleman uh is eligible uh for his
booster i'm not going to ask you mr
speakers inside forbidden to ask him uh
questions but i hope very much that he's
had it
well i can tell the prime minister above
mine kirsten
mr speaker the prime minister says we
should concentrate on what he's asking
the country to do we're asking the
country to follow the rules now the
prime minister the prime minister
doesn't deny there was a downing street
christmas party last year he's not
denied it
he says he says no rules were broken
both of those things can't be true prime
minister he's taking the british public
for falls
and as for following the rules prime
minister
it might be good just to look behind you
when it comes to the question of masks
as ever one rule for them another rule
for everybody else
[Music]
mr speaker at the last election the
prime minister promised to build 40 new
hospitals 40 new hospitals page 10 of
his manifesto with waiting lists so high
prime minister it's a very very
important commitment
now the cabinet office and the treasury
have
checked on progress
and it's reported that they've reached a
damning conclusion i know the chancellor
have seen that they've concluded that
the project needs a red flag because
it's unachievable
prime minister
is that true
prime minister
no mr speaker uh we're getting on with
uh
he he plays politics and asks frivolous
questions mr speaker we're getting on
with delivering on the people's
priorities and we're putting we're
putting record investments into the nhs
on top of the the 34 billion with which
we began and then the 97 billion that we
put in to fight covid uh we we mr
speaker are helping to build another 40
new hospitals with a an injection of 36
billion pounds of investment mr speaker
which that party voted against
[Applause]
well this is strange mr speaker because
the government hasn't been denying the
reports about the red flag and they
haven't done since but now the prime
minister does there's obviously there's
obviously some confusion on these
benches
over whether the cabinet office and the
treasury think he's on course to break
yet another promise this time on new
building of hospitals so he can clear
this up this afternoon if he's so
confident in his answer why doesn't he
publish the progress report in full and
let us all see it
prime minister mr speaker what we're
doing is not only building uh 40 new
hospitals but we are also
but we are also but we are also and it's
incredible uh that we've been able to
keep going throughout the pandemic
but we're also making record investments
in our and yes it is and we're also
making record investments in our nhs we
have more doctors
more nurses working in our nhs than at
any time in the history of that
magnificent organization
and rather than rather than running down
what they're trying to do mr speaker
casting doubt on their efforts he should
get behind them and he should
particularly he should support our
booster campaign
well mr speaker there we have it i deny
the prime minister i deny my hospital
building programs being flagged read as
unachievable but i don't have the
confidence
to erupt to publish the report
mr speaker the more we look at this
promise the murkier it gets
i've got a document here sent by the
department of health
to the nhs
it's called the new hospital program
communications playbook i kid you not
it offers
it offers advice mr speaker to make it
easier to talk about the program now you
might think that everyone knows what a
new hospital is
i certainly thought i knew what a new
hospital is
before i read this document but this
guide instructs everybody to describe
refurbishments and alterations on
existing hospitals as new hospitals
we can all agree we can all agree that
refurbishments are a very good thing
but they're not new hospitals
so prime minister
how many of the 40 are fix-up jobs on
existing hospitals and how many are
actually the new hospitals he promised
prime minister mr speaker you obviously
don't always go around building on
greenfield sites uh what we are doing is
what we are doing is massive
you you rebuild hospitals and that is
what we have said for the last two and a
half years mr speaker it is the biggest
program of hospital building this
country has ever undertaken it's being
made possible by this people's
government and it's in addition to what
we're doing with the community
diagnostics hubs mr speaker and it's a
it's in addition to what we're doing in
investing in our nhs and i i said it
once but i'll say it say it again they
had the opportunity to vote for that 36
billion they turned it down mr speaker
we're getting on with the people's
priorities they're playing politics
and no wonder so many tory donors paid
so much for that wallpaper last year it
probably told me it's building a new
flat
it's the same old story from this prime
minister week in week out defending the
indefensible and broken promises his
mates were found to be corrupt he tried
to get them off the hook
downing street throws parties during
lockdown he says not a problem
he promised to be no tax rises then he
put up tax
he promised to be a real revolution in
the north then he cancelled the trains
he promised no one would have to sell
their home for care then along came his
working-class dementia tax
he promised 40 new hospitals and even if
you count the paint jobs his own
watchdog says he can't deliver it
isn't this the truth mr speaker that any
promises from this prime minister aren't
worth the manifesto paper they're
written on
[Music]
mrs speaker
the right honorable gems the right
honourable gentleman dribbles on
dribbles on irrelevantly about uh about
wallpaper and parties uh playing
politics uh and by the way on that i'm
told i'm told that when the deputy
leader and shadow secretary of state for
the future work was told that she wasn't
invited she denounced it she denounced
it as idiotic childish and pathetic mr
speaker
they're getting on they're getting on
with factional they're getting on with
factional infighting we are delivering
for the people of this country today
today
today cutting tax for the lowest paid
people in this country one as a result
of our universal universal credit
changes 1.9 million families getting a
thousand pounds more in their in their
paying habits this year the biggest
program of rail infrastructure this
century mr speaker three new high-speed
lines and we're fixing social care they
have no plan whatever mr speaker and
don't forget don't forget their their
resort to absolutely every problem is
either to take this country back into
lockdown or to open up to uncontrolled
immigration mr speaker that is
that is their approach we are delivering
on the people's priorities and and we
have more people in work now as a result
of the balanced and proportionate
approach that we are taking than we had
before the pandemic began and if we
listen to him mr speaker if we listened
to captain hindsight we'd all still be
in lockdown and that is the truth
[Applause]
i want to hear to mr roslindale if you
don't come on andrew
thank you thank you mr speaker
the prime minister will know that we
will not
be able to stop the endless waves of
illegal illegal migrants crossing the
english channel
until we break free from the constraints
of the european convention on human
rights
which impedes our ability
to tackle this tragic situation
and protects even the most violent
criminals from being deported so will
the prime minister agree with me that it
is time to take back control
and fulfill
our manifesto commitment
in 2015
to get rid of labour's human rights act
and bring in a british bill of rights
yes mr speaker i thank my uh my right
honourable friend but we will certainly
uh review the human rights system but in
the meantime there is something we can
do or we can all do uh on next tuesday
and wednesday mr speaker because our
borders bill is coming back to this
house after long gestation and it gives
us the power to make the distinction at
last between illegal and legal migrants
uh to this country it gives us the power
to give border force the power to turn
people back from this uh from uh
at sea mr speaker and mr speaker it
gives us the power it gives us the power
to screen people and send them uh for
uh for screening overseas rather than in
this country now uh will that part i'm
not gonna ask them i should tell them
it'd be a great thing mr speaker if the
party opposite backed our borders bill
and undermine the criminals you have the
smp ian blackford
thank you mr speaker and can i associate
myself with the remarks of the prime
minister
on disability and of course uh our
thoughts are very much with all of those
that are recovering from star urban and
with the leader of the opposition of
course we commemorate world aids day and
i'm sure mr speaker that the thoughts of
yourself in this house will be with the
family and friends of siobhan cathigan
the scotland rugby player age 26 who
unfortunately died over the course of
the weekend having had 119 caps for
scotland mr speaker
it is deeply regrettable
that once again that we're forced to
spend so much time in this house
discussing the prime minister's
misconduct
but when the person in charge
so blatantly breaks the rules
it needs to be talked about
last christmas
the prime minister
hosted a packed party in downing street
an event that broke lockdown rules
rules that everyone else
was expected to follow
now the prime minister might be denying
it
but i've spoken to the mirror newspaper
this morning
and they are confirming what happened
and they have legal advice
on potential illegality
at a time when public health messaging
is so vital
how are people
possibly expected to trust a prime
minister
when he thinks it's one rule for him and
one rule for everybody else
well mr speaker i i think they should be
they should concert their line of attack
uh more closely i've said uh before that
he's talking total nonsense i think he
would have been better off frankly
saying something about the victims of
storm irwin in scotland and and what we
want to do
well i'm afraid that i'm afraid if i did
if i didn't hear it he was he was he was
drowned out by his supporters uh but
i think i think i think what we need to
do is work together uh the government of
the uk working with the scottish
authorities to help those people get
their power back and that's what we're
doing in blackfoot this graceful answer
and clearly the prime minister
the prime minister can't even listen
because i mentioned storm irwin
mr speaker the real reason why all this
matters is because we find ourselves at
another very difficult moment in this
pandemic
this is at a time where leadership
matters when truth matters and when
trust really matters
only this morning leaked sage advice
confirms that the uk government's
current international travel
restrictions will identify significantly
fewer cases
that is exactly the same advice that the
prime minister received from the first
ministers of scotland and wales on
monday and he has ignored that advice
since then other countries like ireland
and the us are moving rapidly on
international travel to protect their
people
so will the prime minister finally
convene a four-nation cobra meeting to
tighten travel restrictions or will he
continue to ignore the scottish
government the welsh government and his
own sage advisors and imperil the health
of the public of these islands prime
minister i i i thank the right
honourable gentlemen and of course we
want to work closely with uh with him
and there will be uh opportunity
abundant opportunities today in the
weeks ahead to to concert our activity
but he's simply wrong in what he says
about uh the steps that the government
has taken uh to prevent the seeding of
this of this variant from abroad we were
the this country was actually the first
to respond uh mr speaker and uh for the
ten countries that are most likely to
cede new variant to seed omicron in this
country we've put them on the red list
mr speaker so they have not only
pre-departure tests
but they are also they are also
quarantined mr speaker and and
i have to say that
he is not right in what he says and
every every other country in the world
100
100 percent i don't mind if he shines mr
speaker i will tell him very calmly and
quietly a 100
of the passengers arriving from every
other country in the world must take a
pcr test and they cannot get out of
quarantine mr speaker unless they test
negative those are balanced and
proportionate measures designed to
protect the british people from their
omicron variant and that's the right
approach to take john penrose
mr speaker britain has some of the most
unaffordable child care in the developed
world which reduces opportunities for
working families particularly single
parents deepens gender pay gaps and
makes leveling up much harder so will
the prime minister meet with me to
discuss the proposal in my just
published policy paper poverty trapped
for an immediate review to design out
these internationally uncompetitive
costs while still delivering a safe and
enriching level of care for our children
too
prime minister i i thank my right
honourable fender he is completely right
about the importance of of child care
and the the transformative uh influence
it can have and that's why uh we've
spent 3.5 billion pounds in each of the
last three years on free child care
entitlements particularly uh for the
most disadvantaged but i'm i'm always
happy to meet uh my rival friend and to
discuss uh his ideas further
davey speaker farmers across our country
are crucial to our nation's prosperity
shown once again through the pandemic
but many are now on the brink
farmers across the country in villages
like hodnett bass church wood sieves and
counts others are about to see their
payments cut by at least five percent
starting this very month
the prime minister promised a new
support system rewarding more
sustainable farming
yet in the meantime he seems prepared to
see many british farms go bankrupt
there's an easy solution mr speaker stop
cutting the current system's essential
payments until the new scheme is fully
rolled out
will the prime minister do that and help
our struggling farmers
before it's too late
uh mr speaker i think british food and
farming does an absolutely outstanding
job and it is growing uh the whole time
last night i made i met representatives
of the uk food and farming uh industry
which uh we support and we continue
support uh with uh with the same level
of payments uh mr speaker but what we're
also doing is opening up new
opportunities for them around the world
and i can i can tell him that in every
single embassy now there is a dedicated
uh expert on on supporting uk food and
farming exports to the rest of the world
which supports four million jobs in this
country four million jobs in this
country and earns this country 21
billion pounds of revenue
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
more needs to be done to tackle the
people trafficking gangs that exploit
migrants across europe promising to get
through this country but does the prime
minister agree with me that is totally
unacceptable that companies like
facebook allow those smugglers to offer
their services on their platforms not
only routes into the country but also uh
selling them forged british papers in
order to aid their access does he agree
with me that when we pass this house
passes the online safety bill we'll have
the power to do more to make companies
like facebook take down content that
promotes illegal activity
i i i thank uh the right honourable
gentleman he's absolutely right that uh
too many of these gangs are using social
media and that's why the online harms
bill is so important and it will indeed
be of assistance to us in taking down
that kind of material
thank you mr speaker women have been
left with internal damage and pain they
describe as being like razor blades
inside them many have lost their careers
and some have even lost their lives it
is impossible to know exactly how many
women are left suffering
so why will the prime minister not give
these mesh damaged women the redress
that they were recommended in the
cumberland report
i'm very grateful turn she she raises uh
an extremely important issue and one
that i know has caused a phenomenon that
has caused huge distress to many many
women in this country we published the
the cumberland uh report if there's
anything more that we can do i'm
certainly willing to look at it i'm
grateful to her for raising it london
the leveling up agenda has already
changed so many areas of our country for
the better uh
and in my constituency and workshop
particularly our town centre is in
desperate need of regeneration and to
finally solve our flooding problems but
unfortunately my council in basic law
missed the deadline for the latest round
of grants
on council
what can this government do to help
support areas like mine who have
struggled with their bids in order to
make sure they are successful the next
time around
i i thank you very i thank my older
friend very much well the step number
one is to vote out those dozy labor
counsellors
mr speaker uh but i can tell him uh that
the the thank you for the excellent
representation uh he gives to basset law
uh mr speaker and i can tell the second
round of bidding for the leveling up
fund will open in the spring of next
year
you mr speaker between 2010 and 2019
west midlands police lost 2
221 officers whilst the force should
receive an additional 1200 new recruits
by 2023 via the police uplift program
that still leaves a shortfall of 1 000
officers this lack of frontline police
has left the force stretched and under
significant pressure with officers
actually telling me there are simply
insufficient resources to investigate
every crime
will the prime minister commit to
providing west midlands police with a
fairer funding deal to ensure the force
can return officer numbers back to 2010
levels
[Applause]
mr speaker i thank her for drawing
attention and i'm and she's and i thank
her i think the police officers in the
west midlands but i thank her for
drawing attention to what we're doing to
increase the number of police officers
because we are we're no we are on we are
on track uh of our 20 000 that i pledged
on the steps of downing street uh two
and a half years ago mr speaker we've
already recruited another eleven
thousand and uh and i'm proud to say
that our police officer workforce is
more representative of the whole of this
country with more women more people from
ethnic minorities than ever before
thank you mr speaker last week the first
the chief minister of gibraltar the
honourable fabian picado appeared before
the european scrutiny committee
and gave evidence about the continuing
negotiations between gibraltar and the
european union on their future
relationship
during the course of his evidence the
first the chief minister made clear
that his ambition was that gibraltar's
future should be as he put it british
british british
can my uh right honourable friend say
what the government is doing to support
the first minister to achieve that aim
and in particular to exclude any role
for the european court of justice
prime minister i i thank my right
honourable friend and frankly i can't i
can't really improve on the verdict of
my friend fabian picado the chief
minister of uh of gibraltar uh gibraltar
is british british british and will
remain so and by the way i mr speaker i
do i see no future role for the european
court of justice christine
thank you very much mr speaker my
constituency of edinburgh west are some
of the most polluted streets in our
country an estimated 1 in 29 deaths in
edinburgh is related to air pollution
and we don't meet wh o guidelines so
will the prime minister meet with me and
discuss whether his government can
support my private member's bill to
tackle that issue bring us into line and
let us all breathe a little easier
i thank her for what she is the issue
she mentions it's incredibly important
but that's why
we're moving now to
all out electric vehicles across the
whole of the country uh faster than any
other european country and our clean air
strategy has been praised by the world
health organization as an example for
the rest of the world to follow and
we'll be setting out uh our
evidence-based approach and the targets
uh that we're setting but of course i'll
be very happy to make sure that she
meets the relevant minister to set out
her case david davis
uh thank you mr speaker last month the
drug company pfizer announced a
successful trial of a new treatment
called uh pacslovid the trial showed the
drug to be roughly 90
successful at stopping death or better
the vaccine strategy today is an
enormous success but it leads to a
never-ending biological arms race
against the mutating virus
as a supplement to the vaccine strategy
this treatment will allow governments
around the world to avoid the need for
future emergency restrictions what's the
government doing in the short term to
secure supplies of this revolutionary
treatment and in the long term to enable
factories to be built here to produce it
in britain
prime minister i i thank him very much
and he's spot on uh of course the uh the
rollout of pax lavid uh within the uk uh
within the nhs will depend on approval
by uh the mhra but the government has as
a precaution already uh invested in
hundreds of thousands of courses of that
drone jessica thank you mr speaker wales
has 11
of the uk rail network yet only receives
2 of uk rail enhancement funding and as
reported in wales online will be denied
billions of consequential funding from
hs2 so having under-delivered on rail in
the north having under-delivered on rail
in wales why should anyone trust this
government to deliver on its promises
i'm afraid she's completely failed to uh
to look at what uh
subpoena hindi set out in his union
connectivity review a fantastic agenda
for change and improvement uh
particularly in wells and particularly
in on the north welsh uh corridor where
i think the railway links uh deserve to
be improved and will be improved under
this government
speaker getting investment into gentling
is important and the previous pmq's i
put aside my political differences with
labour run giving borough council to
champion its leveling up fund bid which
like other funding bits it's made has
was sadly unsuccessful so does my right
honourable friend agree with me it's
important that councils like deadly now
take stock and learn from the from this
experience and can you confirm that help
from government will be available to do
that so that in future hopefully
deadline and other accounts will be able
to make more successful bids
yes of course mr speaker we're very
happy to help uh uh gettling and uh and
other labour run councils to get their
act together where necessary and and to
put those and to put those bids in and
just to remind him just to remind him
more leveling up fund uh bids come due
in the spring of next year and i i wish
scheduling well in their future bids
say
mr speaker my grandfather along with
thousands of others came to this country
70 years ago working seven days a week
in squalid conditions to help rebuild
this country
yet now the home secretary's nationality
and borders bill means she can revoke
our british citizenship and deport us
for even the most minor wrongdoings
given the governments and the home
offices horrific track record with their
treatment of minorities the hostile
environment and the windrush scandals
let me ask the prime minister
the burning question that is now on the
lips of everyone from a beam background
right across the country
when is he
coming for me
i think that i think that the right i
think the honourable gentleman opposite
uh should look at the conservative front
bench today and he should withdraw what
he's just said uh mr speaker he should
withdraw
what he said is absolutely shameful and
he knows full well the borders bill does
nothing of the kind it helps it helps us
to fight the evil gangs who are
predating on people's willingness to
cross the channel in unsea-worthy boats
and i would have thought mr speaker that
a sensible labour party would support it
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker this saturday is
small business saturday and i'm proud
i'm proud to represent some fantastic
local businesses like case of grantham
the stanford notebook company and the
bourne bookshop this government has
provided unprecedented support
throughout the pandemic can the prime
minister assure me that his commitment
to our high streets will continue long
into the future
prime minister thank my uh my honourable
friend all the support he gives to
grantham and stanford and i can tell him
uh that small business saturday is
receiving huge support from the uh from
the government we had a a a a
kind of festival last night to celebrate
it in uh in downing street and i
encourage everybody to get out this
saturday mr speaker and uh safely with
your mask on mr speaker when you're in
your shop uh but that's that that should
be no that should be no uh inhibition on
people buying in their shops up and down
this country final question ian
thank you mr speaker
next week the 97 victim of the
hillsborough tragedy will receive the
freedom of liverpool
andrew divine passed away earlier this
year at age 55 having defied the odds to
survive the indonesia sustained at
hillsborough age 22. i cut as an
incredible inquest on liverpool in july
ruled that he was unlawfully killed as a
result of the disaster making him the
97th victim
following my tabling last week of an
80-day motion on hillsborough and our
national curriculum will the prime
minister agree to meet with me to
discuss the roll-outs of the hills rep
real truth legacy project
including the addition of the hills we
disaster to the national curriculum and
help
to consign the history the narrative of
lies and smears peddled by some elements
of the media and establishments over the
last 32 years through the power of
education
prime minister i thank the honorable
gentleman for the powerful point that he
has just made because even though 32
years have passed since that uh
devastating tragedy i know that the the
the wounds uh remain uh very raw in in
liverpool and what i can say to him is
the government is committed as he knows
to continuing engagement uh with the uh
with the families of the of the bereaved
and to making sure that the lessons from
that tragedy continue to be properly
learned and that the victims of
hillsborough are never forgotten mr
speaker but i'm also happy uh to make
sure that he meets the the relevant
minister to take forward an agenda i
think is shared by people up and down
this country
we're now going to come to the
statements to those who wish to leave
come to please leave quickly and quietly
answering the phone
right we now come to the minister